good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it's friday friday gotta get down on
fridays
guys this week has been so long felt
even longer for us because we've had
guests every day which is always a good
time but it's so rare for us i don't
think we've actually in the history of
the show ever had a guest every day
it's a lot of pressure like you know and
then every day i wake up and i'm like oh
i have to be cute like who's coming on
the show what's their vibe like
yesterday i went for a very lady game
vibe and
turned out i looked like a grandma vibe
oh i mean yesterday on the show
physically was the worst i've ever
looked and actually put me into a really
very small depression after the show
like i saw my face and i got my chin
done and i really felt like no matter
how much weight i gained then i've
gained about 20 pounds in the last year
and i like kind of care but not really
my face has always remained trim and
tight and
watching myself on the show yesterday my
face was like back to the balloon face i
used to be
and i couldn't believe what i was
looking at interesting well i just want
to say today on the stream we are both
looking like the snatchers
the sweatshirt is literally in the words
of regina george this sweatshirt is all
that fits me right now
you're crazy no i'm not our vibe is
matching we're plenty as hell
oh yeah i guess i'm like not wearing
black for the first time i weighed
myself this morning and i'm just i'm
really
i'm like so upset i'm sorry to hear that
but you know what march i realized this
morning because i started a diet this
week that i've kept up until friday and
i'm
today i'm actually feeling good because
i've had like four solid good days
but march is the time to get your summer
body because nothing is happening in
march
you know it's like in this calendar when
they call it like bitter the
bitter month there's no holidays it's
like this is the month to get snatched
because we're not going anywhere like
you can
like be good for the whole month and
then you'll have your summer body come
spring i hear you i just this is the
month
i hate that i like have to get snatched
like i just wish i liked the way that i
look do you know what i mean you don't
have to get snatched for anyone other
than yourself
and myself is like hating my body right
so now you have to get snatched so that
come april when we're like in vegas and
maybe in palm springs who knows about
coachella stagecoach
you'll be feeling yourself i'm trying
i'm just like struggling between like
wanting to accept and love myself but
also like looking in the mirror and like
feeling like a beast like it's really
hard
it's it's really hard but you know
pulling down you i think that you look
beautiful today
it's all in your head it's not by the
way
one could say that if i didn't make the
decision to weigh myself today because
it's not in my head no it's right there
like last week i weighed myself and i
was the most i've been uh
in a year and a half and and so that was
them's facts and i felt so terrible
about myself
but what other people see they don't see
that number
i guess that's true i mean i just
whatever it's fine i just this watching
myself on the show yesterday from like a
physical standpoint like i was like oh
my god
why did they let that beast hang out
with the lady gang and it didn't help
like all the members of the lady gang
are like perfect looking
totally it was frustrating by the way we
also recorded an episode of their
podcast
i don't think it's going to go up for
like one or two weeks but it was so
funny like jackie
got to a cri like a laugh where she
actually the podcast was silent
because i was laughing crying telling a
really funny story that i've told before
but
never in such detail and like working
out the reasons of why it was so [ __ ]
awkward i was
crying laughing like tears coming out of
my eyes also speaking of the lady gang
like i know they're so snatch but you
should read their book because you
shouldn't have what i'm actually going
through
this weekend because i think it would
make you feel a lot better about how
you're feeling oh really
okay wait i actually was thinking last
night about how like i have a very
specific genre when it comes to books
like what i like
and i think that this is like an easy to
read book that i will read
yeah and also jessica simpson's book
will make you feel so much i've started
jessica simpson's book but i haven't
taken any trips so it's been hard for me
to read
yeah i think march is the month where we
get it done yeah i'm just like really i
feel like
maybe 50 of the problem i'm feeling with
myself physically is that i need to wax
my lip it's been
quite a minute and i think if i take
care of that today which i'm going to do
my life might change there are some
small things that you could do you know
what else you could do eyebrows get a
spray tan
oh my god you know what sheds five
pounds like that jackie you're so right
i'm going to versus spot today you
shouldn't
i just i'm feeling like an all week it's
just yourself we've had such a good week
like for our business i feel like
we had so many different guests and and
we by the way we had so much fun with
the lady again yesterday if you haven't
seen our tick tock with them
head over on our instagram it's [ __ ]
hilarious it's so good we literally
spent
three hours working on it yeah but uh
kelty and becca are
like choreographers so they made it
premium and they even helped us with our
side yeah they were being like losers
yeah but there she's a [ __ ] rockette
i'm sorry yeah we had no choice but to
listen to her
yeah so it was really funny they're so
fun i had such a good time
spray tan we were with them for like
five hours yesterday i know i was
thinking
i was gonna go to lunch with them but
then i realized we actually spent like
four hours here that like i let them go
to lunch by themselves
um but they're just like the nicest
girls yeah they are and they work really
hard
and no one really talks about how
they're like trailblazers like they
walked so we could run
and we we pay respect yeah we have no
choice but to respect oh i'm sorry also
we both went to the salinas
yes i was getting i knew that you if you
remembered it had been the first thing
that you said
um but i was getting there we both went
to the celine dion concert last night i
have a question for you
did you cry okay so i was with zach and
like for some reason
like when she came out the first three
songs were so beautiful
and her song that's the way it is like
even that's the
reciting the lyrics i could cry when
it's like um
when you want it the most there's no
easy way out
when you're ready to go and your heart's
left in doubt
don't give up on your faith love comes
to those who believe
it and that's the way it
is like those lyrics give me chills like
love comes to those who
don't give up on your face i just got
chills so the whole time i had
tears in my eyes and even when she sang
that song from her new album courage
okay i was about to start that's where
we need to talk
but because of coronavirus i refuse to
touch my face
oh [ __ ] and so i wouldn't let the tears
come down my cheeks because then i would
have had to pat them away
i sat at the barclay center i did not
touch one thing i sat with my hands
clasped
the entire time i did not get a snack i
did not get a drink i did not go to the
bathroom i didn't make me feel so
subconscious i did always
the time i got home i had to pee so
badly
because i would not touch anything oh my
god i totally forgot about corona
zone but also like you were in the front
row so like you weren't as slammed as me
i just have to say like i cannot take
credit for the tickets people are like
how did you get tickets
i've never been to an arena and sat in
the front row i've had very good seats
i've had
seats given to me by an artist and i've
never sat in like
no one in front of you just the stage
and of course brian is slinging down's
number one fan and he was celebrating
his birthday so like
he got a bunch of tickets for his mom
and his friends and he was so nice to
give me one and marge came
and it was a tnn reunion it was a tnn
reunion
literally the the show was incredible i
was freaking out because we went to
dinner at chicony's dumbo which have you
been
of course it was my first time we just
had our book club there it's delicious
and just so
scenic took me 45 minutes to get over
the brooklyn bridge but whatever but you
had to go there anyway
right so we were like planning to to get
there at 8 30 because that's where we
heard she was going on and then in the
middle of our dinner
someone texted me that she actually goes
on at 8 10. so literally it was mayhem
getting in the car because the first
song she sings i know is it's all coming
back to me now and i couldn't miss that
yeah
so we literally got from like i got from
the curb
to my seat in seven seconds like i left
everyone i just couldn't and brian has
seen her so many times
i ran i need to apologize to all the
toasters who i literally like ran by
i just i had to get there for the first
song and i got there like
four minutes to spare it was perfect we
all sat down it's all coming back to me
now like i absolutely lost my mind like
that song means so much to me
mostly because of rachel berry but also
because of celine dion and it was so
spectacular and had tears in my eyes and
then i like calmed down and then i just
enjoyed the rest of the concert
and she did a few covers that i'm not
going to lie i wasn't crazy about
she started this show starts so strong
and at the beginning of the show i was
like
oh my god is she here tomorrow too
because i need to see this she's here
saturday
i kind of want to go again i know i we
have plans that's why we can't oh no but
we have to
oh yeah okay okay wait so okay the
covers i went to the bathroom
and then she was like i'm gonna play
something for my new album and i was
like boo
and i like sat down and brian was like
no you need to listen to the song so me
brian and marge were sitting
and i started like sobbing at this song
it's so sad like it's about
her husband passing away and it's like
courage don't fail me now it's so sad i
literally started sobbing like
margaret and brian were like hugging me
like giving me tissues
it was like so emotional i just wasn't
expecting to be like so taken like
when people are like new music it's like
girlfriend just play the hits but like
you know what she's been going through
in the last two
years you know every word of what that
song means you can relate it to your
past your present
your future like you know that one day
that's how you're going to feel about
someone oh my god
i literally had tears in my eyes and i
was like holding my head back so they
wouldn't drop
so that i didn't know i would touch my
face i was messi oh i was corona vibes i
was muslim like i was so messy at the
concert like
i was sweating i looked so ugly because
i'm i'm a beast these days and i was
wearing like a hat merch that was like
so i played
your hat from my seat uh okay so i could
see tpg from my seat because he's so
tall but i couldn't figure out you and i
hadn't
seen your story so i didn't know what
you were wearing my stories were going
through
and then i saw when she took off the
wristband and threw it and tpg caught it
and then i saw the two of you and i was
like is she wearing a bedazzled hat
i was it was very tamera judge of me and
very unlikely so crazy
i know it was her merch okay i just like
was so it like hating the way that i
look i'm like let me just put this hat
on like to cover it all up
okay i understand that i couldn't
believe that celine dion threw her like
sweaty wristband to brian i mean i could
because brian goes to all of her
concerts and always hits front row
and he's so tall like he's so memorable
so when she was getting ready to throw
it she was like staring at us and like
of course i thought it was she was
staring at me and she was like gonna
throw it to me i was like
oh my god what's happening even if she
was talking to you like brian's wingspan
you were never getting that also like
brian paid for my seat so i would have
had to give it to him anyway
and it was his birthday like it was it
was a lose-lose for me yeah but he still
he let me smell it
that's amazing and it wasn't even sweaty
at all by the way her looks like
her outfits oh my god that big
blouse that the sleeves then came off
and became just like a cute tuxedo
so amazing you guys if she comes to your
town you have to go i couldn't believe
it was my first time i was like
embarrassed that it was my first time
me too and like the crowd was so amazing
i was watching some people who literally
did not sit down once there was this guy
in front of me who was so
so i don't like i remember most of it oh
amazing i i too took a green cab it's
the move
it's the move and you can only take a
green taxi in new york if you're out of
borough so if you're standing in new
york like looking for a cab and a green
one rolls by it won't pick you up
because you cannot be in the city
it's an outer borough taxi and finally i
was out of the borough i never leave the
borough yeah all i will say is that i
was rdh that she did not perform taking
chances
me and brian said that as well brian has
seen her 500 times and you know that
song
is what changed brian's life like he was
working at this job like really wanting
to fulfill his passion project
he was using on his ipod listening to
the song taking chances in the street
and he like stopped and was like i'm
gonna do it
and that song like really like changed
his life and he's never seen her perform
it even though he's seen her everywhere
she doesn't perform it that's so weird i
know
i was i was sad about that but other
than that that's my only complaint it
was it was so incredible
if we are complaining um i just did
think there was too many covers
first of all that song she does with
andrea bocelli was [ __ ] amazing and
she did it better without him
um she did three covers two i had never
heard of and she tried to get the
audience
she did like the blues cover yeah and
then the
with having the crowd be like like i
just wasn't into that but then she did
like a whole medley of covers tina
turner queen
loves that sickening lady marmalade
sickening i loved that and her jumpsuit
yeah the songs that she chose weren't my
favorite like another one bites the dust
if you're gonna like choose a queen song
why is it that one why is it not killer
queen yeah or like
all we hear is radiant yoga
but she did do uh river deep mountain
high which that was amazing
what like i that glee by the way and you
know what i was listening to all these
like old school songs and i was
thinking that the people around me were
like why does this girl know these songs
like they're so not our generation and i
know them from glee
so once again we have no choice but to
respect the lady hank true
true very true well it was great um
yeah i think it's time now for real
because there's no oh i forgot we've
guessed too
much mike sorrentino and lauren the good
news is that the stories are messed so
we'll speed right through them
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and that's true jackie but i'll get
right to it our episode today is brought
to you by bombus
which is very appropriate because damon
john was on our show this week and as he
said it's
they're the most successful company to
come out of shark tank that's crazy but
not so crazy because the socks are
stellar
as you're about to hear working out is
hard it's always been hard even when
it's easy it's still pretty hard
bom preach bomba socks can't change that
but they can make it more comfortable
so if your resolution is to get fit this
year start by getting socks that can
keep up
every step of the way you do a lot of
things to stay active so bombas made a
lot of different performance socks
designed for everything from running to
hiking hiking to cycling and more
whether you're very into sports or
planning on getting very into sports
bombas can help with performance socks
in styles made especially
for basketball tennis running golf and
more they're made with lightweight
polycotton blend
which means no matter how hard you're
working your feet will stay cool dry and
comfortable never sweaty
bomba socks provide support in places
you didn't even know you needed like
your arches
each sock is built with a special arch
support system that's supportive but not
too tight
like a nice hug on your foot a foot hug
constantly pausing your treadmill to
adjust twisted bunched up socks
is enough to make you want to quit
that's why bombus is designed with left
right contouring and a wide stitched
heel
so they stay perfectly in place ever
notice that
that annoying toe seam that socks always
have oh my it's so true that little
ridge on top bomba's got rid of it it's
gone
it's just smooth sailing all the way
across the top of your foot did you know
that the socks are the number one most
requested item in homeless shelters
bomba socks were created to change that
for every pair you buy bomba's donuts a
pair to someone in need
that's so lovely but also like i didn't
even realize what was wrong with
the average shock until bombas made like
a much better one they're always
slipping
the toe seam and you know if you have a
if you have a crusty toenail
you can make a hole in your sock because
if they're cheap oh for sure but the
seam like a crunchy toenail could just
cut right through that
at one point i was wearing such terrible
socks that i was like giving myself like
an
ingrown toe because that sock was
jamming into my toenail
at all times obama says fix that go to
bombus.com
toast today and get 20 off your first
purchase that's b
o m b a s dot com slash toast for 20
off bombas.com toast
sign on keep your feet warm yeah okay
first
story a little good news taylor swift
has donated one million dollars to
tennessee tornado relief
proud i'm proud taylor swift is donating
1 million to tornado relief
efforts in middle tennessee where deadly
storms ravaged countries this week
including nashville
counties not countries sorry i was like
oh my god
there's just like a one different letter
yes in the words in an instagram post
made thursday she said nashville is my
home and the fact that so many people
have lost their homes and so much more
in middle tennessee is devastating to me
i've made a donation to the middle
tennessee emergency response fund
if you'd like to do the same swipe up i
mean we just love a philanthropic queen
taylor swift is
always always being very philanthropic
and never um discusses it publicly if
people know about it it's because
it was released through no doing of her
own so this is the first time that she's
been
charitable but also been public about it
but that's because she's trying to
garner funds from other people
um i just love it like she's finally
being recognized for her philanthropic
work and not like hiding it under the
rug like when she was in boston giving
like
3 000 tickets like families of fallen
police on firefighters like
you have no choice i do feel like we
associate her
as being very philanthropic like she
paid kesha's legal funds i also heard
a rumor that she was going to pay all of
those legal penalties that kesha had to
pay the new ones yeah the new ones i
heard that too
um not confirmed or anything but i heard
that yeah
so i'd love to see a philanthropic queen
getting a great example you know when
you hate taylor swift people love to be
like she's only doing it so like people
talk about it you know what i don't even
care if that's true but the million the
money's still great
yeah money is money and it's going to
the right places so
do what you got to do the ends justify
the means agreed i hope that um all of
our national toasters are doing okay
it's
so crazy how crazy out of nowhere i feel
like i mean i
don't know i've never really experienced
a tornado like with a hurricane you get
warning like people
evacuate like people just woke up and it
was everything was gone yeah
so scary so scary so wizard of oz yeah
so wizard of oz it's really crazy but
i'm glad that
people are really stepping up to help
yeah and i just want to say like the
storm chasers really put themselves in
danger and like
to like get video of the storm like
those people are so dumb
like i just think like what it's just
like
i know it's like a job it's like an
adrenaline thing like people some people
go skydiving like some people like
get in their pickup trucks and like
chase a tornado it's so dumb i just want
to put out there like stop doing that
i honestly you're putting yourself in
danger and then like first responders
who have to come get your dumb ass
i'm not familiar with this
industry you know there's literally
people who like when they're when people
are like
evacuating or like there's a tornado
like they want to get it on tape and
they like
stay to film it interesting and then
they like
drive in their truck like just in the
minute just in the nick of time it's so
stupid
oh that's crazy that's kind of like
brody jenner exactly but he wasn't
he wasn't filming it he was fighting it
and he was trying to yeah he was trying
to save his house trying to save his
house i think that he did
i think that he did too because he
covered in water yeah
so crazy but let's just stop chasing
storms okay um
another very charitable story is that
tony robbins has raised 18 million
dollars for charity with his 60th
birthday party
i know he's a controversial queen yeah
16 million dollars like i said money is
still green
for operation underground railroad which
combats child
sex trafficking i mean we have no choice
to respect the charitable act but i'm
just not
um i'm not going to comment further on
tony robbins he's one of those people
where it's like
are you canceled or not definitely not
canceled
his birthday party was star studded what
yeah um it was at microsoft theater and
uh gerard butler was there julian huff
annette betting paris hilton
they watched pitbull melissa etheridge
and cold war kids perform
this is where cancer culture gets dicey
because it's either we have to cancel
everyone or no one you know no i don't
even think he's close to cancelled no no
i think he's had some unflattering press
and the world kept turning for him but
also he owns his business so
right it would have difference his
people you know
choosing no longer to believe in him but
i think he's changed so many people's
lives
and and i'm actually really unfamiliar
with what he does
same because i thought he was like a
religious figure but he's like a
motivational speaker
sans religion but he talks a lot about
god yeah
he's just a life like a very highly
respected
life coach and now julianne huff is like
getting on
his team like she i only saw because
jackie schimel went to the event like
instagram story the whole thing
and she does like her dance energy like
dinner g or something
like no it's like julianne's dance
energy like energy like i don't know
what the name is it's so dumb
and she like dances and like power like
speaks powerfully and motivates people
in like huge arenas and it's very
similar so it makes sense that she was
at tony robbins um birthday party but
it's just i but people love it like the
kardashians go and it's like 11 hour
motivational speaking things like yeah
it's
it's not i don't i don't i don't know
what it is it's like a cult but like not
religious
and not really a cult because you could
leave yeah and no one's gonna brand you
but it's like
it's kind of like the toast yeah well
anyways great for them that's a lot of
money to raise for a really good cause
yeah so
how was it raised like through people
donating yeah i'm sure and like they had
performances so they probably had like a
crowd
funding situation yeah yeah with the big
names in the room
dr oz and maria menounos hosted oh
interesting yeah so they were probably
just getting that coin you know
professional hosts totally love to see
it okay next story isn't really a story
it's more of a photo
because meghan markle and prince harry
have a movie star moment in the rain
megan markel and prince harry have
stepped out they
are back in the uk they went to the
annual endeavor fund awards in
london on thursday this is their really
their last week slash month of royal
duties
and it's also like their first public
appearance together since the whole
drama
yes and they stepped out at this event
it was raining between the flashing
camera lights reflecting off the rain
and the duo sharing megawatt smiles
and an umbrella megan and harry look
straight out of a hollywood blockbuster
movie glamour this photo we posted it to
the toast instagram so if you don't know
what we're talking about
just go check it out i saw it and
literally my jaw dropped it took my
breath away it
is so iconic i think that this is the
photo that they are going to use of
megan and harry for
generations in textbooks in textbooks
like it is their iconic photo i honestly
i don't think that their iconic photo
like came on the day of their wedding
i'm not gonna lie
but this photo not only like do they
look so beautiful
the way that they're looking at each
other the rain
they it's literally you couldn't stage a
better photo
and i think the fact that you know the
surrounding circumstances like this is
their last week of royal duties
they look so happy and they're putting
out this vibe of like we made the right
choice for ourselves right like this is
like the epitome of like
taking care of yourself like look what
happens when you make decisions
for you and for nobody else and it's
like her makeup is
the sickening her dress is so beautiful
but none of it
is out of the ordinary it's just a blue
dress yeah the photo
and the moment is extraordinary and her
little smile when she looks at the
camera is just so picture-perfect this
photo of her on harry's arm where she's
just like turned to the side looking at
the camera
she's so beautiful her skin is stunning
it's
really i just don't remember the last
time a photo
has been captured that's so iconic like
it will be remembered forever like for
me
this should be times photo of the year
by the way it's 100
a contender i just and you know what it
makes me excited because
it seems like they're so happy they're
just you know oozing glamour
and does this mean that we're gonna get
more photos like this going forward
because
that's what i'm here for she has time
for herself now you know i'm not even
like a member of like
britain so i don't care that they're not
serving my country anymore
you know i'm not a member of britain you
know what i mean like yeah i don't
i don't it doesn't happen in the game of
like they're not serving their royal
duties but now they're serving their
glamorous duties
and that is where we are members and
that's where we come in yeah i just
i think this is good i feel like if
anyone ever doubted their decision to
leave you see this picture and you're
like this was the right choice
for them yeah and then we got this photo
so i don't know if we would have gotten
this photo
like maybe she would have chose a
different outfit a different hairstyle
if she was still a royal
we just got like these series of photos
or maybe someone else would have been
carrying their umbrella
right it's like the umbrella and the
rain and the snatcher of it all
her dress is victoria beckham and it's
sold out obviously get the photo of them
from the back
no this whole evening the rain like rain
is so annoying it's become one of my
least favorite things
ever since we moved into the studio oh
of course but it can just be
so glamorous and that's why you know
taylor swift loves doing concerts in the
rain that's what i was gonna say
when we went to her show in the rain it
added to the experience because we were
all just like these
little swamp monsters you have to not
care about like your hair and your
makeup
and at a taylor swift concert all you
care about is a performance i went to a
wedding in the rain once it was
in like austin in the summer and just
for the 45 minutes of the ceremony
monsoon and it was an outdoor ceremony
indoor party
but what they did and like it was such a
beautiful couple who loved each other so
much
and they had everyone who's in the
bridal party hold an umbrella okay
and they made a hoopa out of the
umbrellas just like in the nick of time
and it was
it wouldn't have been as magical without
it you know then it just sometimes but
sometimes it does ruin
another beautiful wedding right i just
thought it added it really added um
speaking of meghan markle's
incredibly glamorous moment if you want
to look something like a mega star maybe
a princess
you need to know about charlotte tilbury
she's one of the most highly regarded
and influential celebrity makeup artists
of all time
she's a groundbreaking female
entrepreneur and founder of her
eponymous company
charlotte tilbury beauty with 27 years
in the beauty industry
she's been responsible for the creation
of countless iconic beauty styles and is
regarded as a visionary and trendsetter
in 2013 she forever changed the face of
global beauty with the launch of her
makeup and skincare collection decoding
her traditionally closed door vip
expertise giving women and men the tools
to be the most beautiful versions of
themselves
her client list when it comes to
celebrities is iconic we got
kate moss amal clooney jennifer aniston
naomi campbell christy turlington
sama hayek miranda ker nicole kidman
anyone who's fabulous
jackie claudia ashrae soon to be
charlotte tilbury and charlotte tilbury
beauty have won over 280 awards globally
worked on over 180 magazine covers
and 600 plus editorial advertising
campaigns
her products are hyper curated with
charlotte's innovative know-how and are
easy to choose and easy to use
each product in the range includes
instructions on how to use
how to use it and as well as engaging
tutorials and video content alongside
every product
her pillow talk collection is
charlotte's best-selling globally adored
nude pink shade that's on everyone's
lips actually margaret joseph had it at
the concert last night
and in the name of carnivarus i did use
it as well um it's a little
scene it's a little black dress of
makeup versatile and dreamy the perfect
pink nude
shade to bring out the most beautiful
version of you the proof is in the
numbers it's america's
most loved lipstick they loved pillow
talk in 2019 it was the number one
lipstick in the us
and as of january 16th of this year
there are now more pillow talk shades to
love
charlotte is expanding her iconic pillow
talk collection to include medium and
intense shades
of each cult pillow talk product so
there's a lipstick a lip liner a blusher
and an eye palette
the adored iconic shade is now available
to flatter everyone's natural beauty and
can be used to dial up your look for
every mood
from day to day to date and beyond
charlotte tilbury is shoppable directly
from charlottetilbury.com as well as our
free
well not r they are freestanding beauty
wonderland at the grove in la
they're sold at most nordstrom and
sephora's in north america visit
charlottetilbury.com
for store finder thank you charlotte
tilbury for sponsoring this next story
love it sign on become the snatcher i
absolutely love charlotte tilbury and
i'm so excited to be working with them
no i know i mean first of all a
redheaded queen has no choice but to
respect a fellow redheaded queen no when
i use so much of their products pill
talk is truly like the number one lip in
the game i saw her uploading dales once
oh yeah it was fabulous fabulous she's
very tall okay next up speaking of
people who are fabulous
demi lovato celebrates self-love in her
new single i love me
with an accompanying music video that
was not really subtle at all
no throughout the new music video so do
you like it because it's just
overt yeah throughout the new music
video the singer takes a trip down
memory lane as she walks through the
streets of new york as moments from her
past
pass her including the jonas brothers
and a reference to her overdose
and wilma valderrama at the end yes um
the song is very i think this is like a
new trend on the nose
yeah it's like not subtle and i'm loving
it like we had that with katy perry song
yesterday even the celine dion song that
we heard last night
it's called courage by the way the song
is her grief um and the tour is called
courage too
uh i just like we just listened to the
song in the studio it's super cute
it's cute it's not her typical like
belty more like
anthemy vibe but you gotta give you
yes but it also has a lot of heart and i
also feel like i hope it plays on the
radio
because anyone like sitting in the back
of the car like feeling terrible about
themselves because they just weighed
themselves hi that's me and listens to
the lyrics and realizes that like you
need to love yourself
more and before you can love anyone else
i think it's a great message like
josie and the pussycat style to be
ingraining into the young minds totally
and the young minds
are wild and out i mean did you see all
this controversy with the tick tock kids
they're all in it they're all at the
cove in atlantis and they're all like
tick-tocking and they're like little
bikinis and like people are like all up
in arms about it
who like perez hilton like literally
being like these kids like my kids when
they're
15 they're not going to be in their
reading suits advice and charleston on
tick tock
he's he comes up on my favorite page i'm
about to block him just so i can stop
getting his videos right now they're so
cringy like and they're so terrible
um and he's just like comment it's like
okay if you think it's weird that 15
year olds are
in their bikinis on tick tock sure what
i think is weird is an old man
talking about their bodies yeah like
that's creeping yeah
i've seen these this vacation content i
love it they're having so much fun
they're real kids with like real bodies
it's i mean i'm obsessed with addison
i've become like her number one fan and
her body is just
perfect like and it's not crazy
unattainable it's just like a kid's body
i know that sounds so weird
yeah i totally uh i agree completely
they never face
and like let their parents uh parent
them the internet doesn't need to
they have parents yeah and they're very
active the parents yeah and the kids are
having a good time the kids seem all
right you know yeah
so the kids are all right fifth and
final story before we bring out mr and
mrs
sitch nicki minaj's husband has been
arrested by the feds for not
registering as a sex offender nicki
minaj's husband's past is coming to bite
him in the ass as he's been arrested by
u.s marshals
on an indictment for failing to register
as a sex offender tmz has learned
kenneth petty was in federal court
custody wednesday we're told he turned
himself into the marshals
according to court docs he'll face a
judge later today
and then the update is that he appeared
in court and pled not guilty i think one
of the weirdest
flexes of 2020 is nicki minaj very
quietly being married to a sex offender
yes very quiet except for today yeah i
just i wanted to talk about it because
it's so weird like these are not real
people problems you know like
oh my husband forgot to go to court for
a sex offender child to register as a
sex offender it's just so
weird so forgetful and it's like who who
could be married to someone like
i don't know i mean i think there are
people on the sex offender registry who
are like genuine like
like it sucks like on a lawn otter sv
what happens all the time where it's
like this 19 year old was like dating a
17 year old you know and it's like
that's
statutory rape like to me that's not a
sex offender like a sex offender is this
guy like being accused of molesting his
little child his little cousin
yeah but also her husband's a sex
offender and her brother
is a sex offender you know she she keeps
good company she does
she really does she has you know at
least she's consistent
totally also wait before we bring out mr
and mrs i want to touch briefly on love
is blind reunion yes of course
because um i watched it last night and
it was nice to put a bow on things and
see where things shook out
but the reunion was trash okay you know
i 100
agree and it's so funny how i feel as
though a lot of reality and unscripted
shows are following the bravo formula
but nobody can do it like bravo can no
and i just thought the set was so trashy
honestly i liked them but vanessa
vanessa and nicolas were horrible like
there was no fluidity like the questions
were weird there was all over the place
like choppy chop chop
choppy chop chop i felt like it was cut
up on imovie to me the only interesting
thing was that giannina and
um damian are together but if you're in
the toasters blind group you know that
they've been together since the day of
the wedding
yeah it was rough i think vanessa lachey
did better she but that's also because
she is more of a host um
it was really strange but you can't
compare season one
reunion of love is blind to season ten
reunion
go back and watch a season one right
there that they got so much [ __ ] for
but i just feel like it was weird
because they would say how have you been
in the last year and a half and you're
supposed to sum up your year and a half
in one sentence well i'm sure they had
more time but they cut it to 45 minutes
it was just so boring
and it was so boring the clip they
released was the only interesting part
of amber calling jessica scheisti and to
be honest
i felt bad for jessica at the reunion
like honestly i would not have shown up
she was like a joke of the season
literally everyone is saying such mean
things about her online like it took a
lot of balls for her to get up there
and to be honest it's like she's single
now and you're in a happy marriage with
barnett like just let it die
yeah except oh oh and oh my god
okay the kelly and kenny stuff was
actually really interesting because you
could tell i think that
kelly actually maybe have regretted a
little bit not being with kenny and
kenny's in this new fabulous
relationship
and kenny's girlfriend is a toaster well
maybe i think she might be
tbg knows her we were talking about it
last night wow yeah she works for tbg's
company
oh my god yeah crazy wow i love to see
that i'm glad that kelly
realized you know
like yeah and it was just like she was
the one who said no to him and then like
they're at this reunion and she's like
kind of there with like
he's like so happy and she's like yeah
i'm still single you know yeah and she's
crying
yeah and he's strong the teachers have
turned it it was interesting to see how
different people look after a year and a
half though bardette looks so different
diamond looks so different amber amber
like everyone looks so different except
lauren and cameron look the same to me
giannina cut her hair she looks the same
damien looks the same it's just weird
how like people like age in a year and a
half
yeah i just feel like i didn't get what
i wanted out of it but what i got like i
didn't
need i don't know i don't know what i
wanted to explore like
what's going on with mark he got no air
time
he got no air time i've been seeing
toast's blind that he's like majorly
thirsty he was engaged when he went on
the show or some [ __ ] like there was a
rumor that he was um
had a girlfriend but he went on to be
there and buy podcast and said that's
not true
oh okay but there's something strange
about him and like i feel like jessica
could have used that opportunity to be
like listen
mark was giving me like what every girl
wants but there was something
not adding up right and he went home and
he did this and that like she should
have called him out
yeah but you know what i think she just
wanted it to be over yeah and you know
what i respect like i i'm
done like digging you shouldn't you know
[ __ ] because these are
real people and i think you go on tv and
you expect you know people are going to
criticize you but the magnitude that
love is blind
and the the scale at which like it's
really taken over the world
they never expected that and so for that
reason i'm letting it go
um okay we're gonna bring out mike the
situation and his wife lauren if you
have questions for them please drop it
in the youtube stream and our segment
with them is brought to you by
betterment
here's an honest question how are you
supposed to know what to do with your
money
very few of us are exposed to meaningful
advice on how to manage our finances
even fewer have the means to get
professional financial guidance
betterment is a platform that was built
to do something radical
give accessible financial advice that
puts you first if you're like most
americans your money is probably sitting
in a savings account
likely earning you next to nothing maybe
you have an investment account that
you're not really sure what to do with
betterment can help you make sense of
what to do with your money investing
involves risk
but you don't have to know the ins and
outs of the stock market to start saving
or start investing it for your future
betterments technology will put your
money to work choosing the stocks and
strategies that are right for you
because we know you have other things to
do like listen to the toast betterment's
platform can even provide you
with guidance on what financial goals
make sense for you give your money a new
home with betterment peace of mind
included
download the betterment app today that's
b-e-t-t-e-r
for the betterment of you we will be
right back with the sorrentinos stay
tuned go get a snack go to the bathroom
don't go far
we are back with the situations the
sorrentinos and now
podcast hosts mike and lauren welcome to
the morning toast
oh my god thank you guys thank you for
having us guys this is so exciting you
guys just launched your podcast last
week
first episode it's called here's the
sich yes great name
thank you when you were calling yourself
the situation back in the day like did
you know
were you doing it for branding purposes
because now you have this whole brand
and you can use the name
your youtube is the situation but was it
just a funny nickname or were you always
forward thinking
um at the time in college my nickname
was uh mikey abs and i didn't think that
was going to stick
right okay what if you get hungry
when i had my first interview with uh
mtv they were like what is your nickname
so um i came up with the situation and
their response was very
was very telling that i should call my
attorney immediately to trademark the
situation because they were like oh my
god that's so cool
and so that's where the situation was
born about 10 years ago and lauren do
you like being mrs situation
i do like being missed a situation
that's great
yeah so tell us about the podcast why'd
you want to start it and what's
what's the strategy well technically i
didn't want to start the podcast uh
my wife is the one or the brains of this
operation here
and she's like we should start a podcast
and we should start a youtube channel
hence we started both uh right around
the time when i got home from
uh prison and um we're really big into
positivity
yeah and a lot of times we don't think
that we see that often so we wanted to
spread that message
you know to people out there that are
going through obstacles or depression or
anxiety or
just life's challenges because we feel
that we've been through a lot of
situations and have a lot of
wisdom to share yeah it's so interesting
like your arc you've really reformed so
much and i feel like you were such a
changed person even before you went to
prison like that one season we saw was
like
kind of heartbreaking just to see you
being in such a better position in your
life
but still having to like go back to that
that darkness um
where how are you doing now uh we're
doing fantastic
uh we've been out of prison for a couple
months
the wife was actually in prison
technically too she was holding down the
fort
at home with moses our dog and she was
away from her husband i was on the front
line
for eight months and we had just gotten
married so that's technically to be
honest with you guys
that's not a cool situation so she also
had to
she also was in the trenches too but
we're doing really awesome right now
thank you
can you explain or uh go into the
decision to get married before prison i
loved it
yes um the decision was the fact that um
you know we were going through a very
stressful time and we were so in love
and we wanted to sort of uh get married
i had engaged the prior season on jersey
shore and it was such a beautiful moment
and i really didn't want you know what
we were going through to sort of stop us
from really just cementing our love and
our relationship
and getting married and sort of living
happily ever ever after
so um after we got engaged the next
season jersey shore
said you know do you guys want to get
married and i said i definitely do
um but i was also going to prison that
season as well
so it wasn't a very easy